dans un instant nous recevrons jérôme
commandeur
l'excédent jérôme commandeur que j'ai
toujours connu avec du succès d'ailleurs
c'est vrai il est 10h sur le succès
depuis des années des années maintenant
c'est une carrière incroyable jérôme
commandeur c'est fou c'est un des plus
drôles de france et un de mes amis des
plus drôles également voilà j'ai mouillé
prémont avant avant la dépression avant
largement la russie
jérôme lui a su appréhender le succès
c'est un peu ce qui n'a pas su faire
jérôme et bien nous voir pour un film ce
film s'appelle irréductibles
irréductibles qui va les voir
il va aller le revoir pour payer
à voir la bande-annonce
reste avec nous parce que vous allez
voir jérôme commandeur sur le plateau
dans un instant il sera là
jusqu'au petit oignon
heureux oui oui c'est fait un peu froid
mais
mialet comme il est beau de loin et
dépôts de prêts et baux de partout
j'adore en garde c'est quoi cette pause
banon mais je vous attends non mais
tu faisais pas des choses comme ça avant
que je connaissais ses fouquet quoi ça
c'est quoi c'est le succès regardez
mais regardez regardez ils peuvent faire
n'importe quoi ici c'est fou ça regardez
les chics
brdt chiquissime je t'en prie
je t'en prie
je mette la bande annonce non voilà
c'est plus la tête
j'en suis
s'il vous plaît amenez-le ou un manteau
quelque chose il
attend la bande annonce il a une tournée
à faire après fait la tournée des
cinémas j'ai pas envie qu'on retrouve
iran le commandant a révélé voilà des dd
je sais pas quoi dire ça va la santé ça
va bien ça va vous les enfants
vous la sentez tout simplement oh oui ça
va ça va j'ai eu un peu peur parce que
là on a eu chaud très tôt cette année
y'a plus de saison de base hors saison
et on va se retrouver 40 en novembre ça
nous prend les les boules de neige on
descend sous le nez est temps qu'elle
père noël c'est vrai oliveira un show
fois il sera là mais le concept
vous êtes toujours dans le métier
un petit peu on vivote on vivote
mellacois on est toujours à un pied dans
le paf un pays dans le pays dans le
schéma tactique aussi voilà non non
voilà on est là on vivote pourquoi nos
combattants mais si un jour vous faites
une émission
assez bout un jour faire un film des
bois
pour la santé paca
attente est bien sympa avec tes petites
baskets americana est tombé loin mais
bon pour l'instant c'est quoi as tu bien
pourquoi j'avais un film qui s'appelle
réductible toutefois les besoins parole
c'est quoi l'histoire
c'est un gars
[Rires]
c'est un gars des eaux et forêts limoges
vous connaissez oui bien sûr vincent
pelletier exactement eh ben il est
il faire on ferme le service d'accord et
donc pour le faire sortir
d'administration s'il veut pas sortir
dans une station on a lutté dans les
coins les plus dégueulasses jusqu'au
groenland où on va le
protéger il va protéger les chercheurs
sur les scientifiques des attaques
d'ours exaltant et l'as adema ce qui est
marrant c'est que ça démarre comme une
petite blagounette et sa part en comédie
aventure je sais c'est énorme et on
entité devrait pas franchement une fois
de plus jérôme commandeur montre que
sita c'est un des plus grands acteurs
français je vous le dis j'ai jamais
rencontrées lors jamais rencontré mais
je sais que voilà et
c'est ce que je pense de lui c'est ce
que je pense de lui j'ai le compteur des
taxis qui tourne
[Rires]
au cul les [ __ ] nos ondes aucune des
deux ne veut pas mais on va plus me
voilà justement c'est le crois pas avant
ces trois pas qu'est-ce qui prend bien
la lumière
regardez quand il rentre dans la lumière
comme un insecte fou regarde on prend
souvent pour patricia kaas
voulait dire non non non
gmac la bande-annonce quand même oui
alors reporté au bout du couloir
vous êtes payés pour faire ça
c'est vrai on arrive à joindre les deux
bouts à aller
irréductibles qui l'a vu qu'il a vu dans
un instant jérôme commandeur sera avec
nous sur le plateau juste avant on va
regarder la bande-annonce
d'irréductibles il sert au regard des
terrasses et pas toi vincent qu'est ce
que tu veux faire plus tard beaucoup de
temps à y voir entre est loin d'être en
vacances mais moi je travaille et quel
métier va permettre de faire ça plus
tard fonctionnaires comme messieurs
voici ton permis de chasse j'ai jeté
apporter des cayes des commerciaux
fallait pas les fonctionnaires seront
encouragés au départ en temps voulu si
vous refusez mouche et j'ai vomi tu es
dans un endroit pareil du tout ils
veulent qu'elle irait il propose des
mutations dans les endroits impossibles
je vais moi je signe
mes deux places femmes passent en poste
à pourvoir dans une fosse et paiera un
égout une sanisette ce que vous voulez
démerdez-vous métro et le mois votre
travail consiste à protéger les
chercheurs de la station contre les
attaques d'ours polaires
rien n'y fait le direct à l'entregent
lors d'un apéro j'ai des amis vous
n'avez jamais eu un cas mieux vaut en
effet la [ __ ] je vous rassure fabrice a
été très bien reconnue non même tu peux
gradé le bi ssas si cela vous arrive on
va laisser refroidir l'eau tu me le
signalent un certificat de devenir nonne
habilitation de les chercheurs avec qui
vous êtes supposés travailler à l'issue
de ces chercheurs il ce sera quelqu'un
d'autre j'attends de vous un bon nombre
je vais retourner si je vais [ __ ] mon
doigt au hasard dessus et je bute
pelletier à l'endroit du doigt
tiens bon vincent tient bon
on veut où cette fois ci il fait pas
confiance aux blancs parce qu'ils sont
égoïstes impoli et arrogant c'est pas
faux mais c'est une toute petite partie
des blancs qu'on mettait les parisiens
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
très contente le vent c'est un christian
un connard qui s'est passé pourquoi
peter
larmichette votre égard